We spend our 20s chasing what we think
matters. Fancy job titles and Instagram
experiences, perfect relationships. But
in your 30s, the game changes
completely. Your 30s aren't about
checking boxes. They're about building
foundations while you still have runway.
Most people waste their 30s optimizing
for the wrong things. They focus on
climbing ladders leading to walls they
don't want to scale. What actually
matters? Starting retirement savings.
Now, the difference between investing at
30 versus 40 isn't just 10 years. It's
often hundreds of thousands of dollars.
What matters is relationships that
reciprocate your energy, not your social
media following. What matters is
sustainable health habits, not 30-day
challenges you'll abandon. What matters
is saying no without guilt. It's the
single most powerful tool for creating
the life you actually want. Your 30s
aren't about having it all figured out.
They're about figuring out what actually
deserves your precious time and energy.